♪ ♪
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
ON JANUARY 261973 MOST 50 YEARS
AGO SEVEN MEMBERS OF THE
SUPREME COURT, THE SAME
CONSTITUTION THAT AMERICANS HAD
FOUGHT AND DIED TO PROTECT
ELECTED OFFICIALS COULD NOT
PROTECT THE UNBORN FROM
ABORTION.
EVER SINCE TIME ABORTION HAD
BEEN A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
NOW THIS IS A PAINFUL AND
HUMILIATING EXPERIENCE WHO LOVE
THIS COUNTRY.
WHO ARE ASHAMED TO THINK THAT
OUR CONSTITUTION WOULD BE USE TO
JUSTIFY ABORTION.
THE PRO-LIFE COMMUNITY NEVER
GAVE UP WAS BELIEVE THAT SOMEDAY
ROE V. WADE WILL BE OVERTURNED
AND WITH BLOOD ON OUR HISTORY
WILL BE PURGED AND TODAY IS THAT
DAY.
>> THIS IS AMAZING.
THIS IS THE BEST DAY OF AMERICAN
HISTORY IN MY LIFETIME.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THIS IS WHAT A PRO-LIFE
FEMINIST LOOKS LIKE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: A LOOK AT ALL THOSE
YOUNG WOMEN AND MEN CELEBRATING
LIFE.
THAT IS THE FUTURE OF AMERICA.
THE PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT, BUT THERE
ARE SOME WHO SEEM THAT ABORTION
A HOLY SACRAMENT AND THEY ARE
FURIOUS THEY'RE TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE THE JUSTICES AT THEIR
HOMES THREATENING TO DEFY THE
COURT THEY ARE DESPERATE TO
INFLAME THE NATION AS IT WAS IN
THE SUMMER OF 2020.
>> THIS DECISION MUST NOT STAND.
LEGAL ABORTIONS.
>> [BLEEP].
WE ARE NOT YOUR INCUBATORS.
>> Laura: THE MAJORITY SIMPLY
RETURNS THE ISSUE OF ABORTION TO
THE STATE WHERE IT PROPERLY
BELONGS.
IT WILL BE LEGAL IN MANY STATES,
BUT ILLEGAL OR HIGHLY RESTRICTED
IN OTHERS.
UNTIL THE PEOPLE DECIDE
DIFFERENTLY.
IT'S CALLED A DEMOCRATIC PROCESS
EVER HEARD OF IT?
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD KNOW BETTER OF
COURSE THEY ARE ENGAGED IN WHAT
CAN ONLY BE DESCRIBED AS
PATHETIC AND LAME EFFORTS TO
TWIST THE RULING.
CHIEF AMONG THEM JILL BIDEN
HIMSELF.
>> President Biden: IT
WAS 3 JUSTICES NAME BY THREE BYE
PRESIDENT.
THEY LIMITED THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT OF WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
STATE LAWS BANNING ABORTION ARE
AUTOMATICALLY TAKEN EFFECT TODAY
JEOPARDIZING THE HEALTH OF
MILLIONS OF WOMEN SOME WITHOUT
EXCEPTIONS.
SO EXTREME THAT WOMEN COULD BE
PUNISHED FOR PROTECTING THEIR
HEALTH.
LIBERTY, DIGNITY, AND THE
STABILITY OF THE RULE OF LAW
DEMAND THAT ROE V. WADE SHOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN OVERTURNED WITH
THIS DECISION.
A CONSERVATIVE MAJORITY OF THE
SUPREME COURT SHOWS HOW EXTREME
IT IS.
HOW FAR REMOVED THEY ARE UP FOR
THE MAJORITY COUNTRY.
THIS DECISION MUST NOT BE THE
FINAL WORD.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND, I
THOUGHT COURT RULINGS OR THE LAW
OF THE LAND SHOW I ALWAYS SET
OUT THE WINDOW NOW?
I WILL HAVE TO TAKE NOTES HERE.
NOW THIS IS SO TYPICAL OF PEOPLE
WHO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS
WRONG.
JOE BIDEN AS A CATHOLIC, SHOULD
BE ASHAMED OF HIMSELF.
TO USE THE WORD DIGNITY TO
JUSTIFY THE ROE V. WADE
DECISION.
THE WORST WAS HIM CONJURING UP
PHONY EMOTIONS HE WAS EVOKING
OUTLIER CASES IN ORDER TO WHIP
UP POLITICAL SUPPORT FOR THE
LIFELESS PARTY.
>> IT SERVED THEIR WORKFORCE TO
BIRTH THEIR CHILD.
A CHILD OF CONSEQUENCE.
IT JUST STUNS ME.
>> Laura: WHAT A PHONY I'M
SORRY.
IF DEMOCRATS THINK THAT THIS CAN
HELP THEM IN NOVEMBER.
WE SORELY MISTAKEN.
IT'S USUALLY NOT GOOD FOR ANY
POLITICAL MOVEMENT TO BE LOSING
AMERICANS ARE SEEING A POPULIST
MOVEMENT IS WINNING AND IT IS
SUCCEEDING.
HISPANICS WERE MORE PRO-LIFE
THAN MOST DEMOCRATS ARE KNOCKING
TO TURN AWAY FROM THE G.O.P.
BECAUSE THEY SUDDENLY WANT MORE
ABORTIONS AND NO ONE IS GONNA
TOLERATE A TERRIBLE ECONOMY WAY
FOR WAR SPENDING AND COMPETENCE
JUST SO MORE PEOPLE CAN GET MORE
ABORTIONS THAT IS LUDICROUS.
I NOTICED THE DIFFERENCE BY THE
WAY BETWEEN THE WAY WE REACT TO
LOSING AT THE COURT IN THE WAY
THEY DO.
I'LL PRO-LIFE FORCES LOST 50
YEARS AGO.
IT WAS DAVE DEVASTATING AT THEM,
BUT THEY NEVER STOPPED BELIEVING
IN AMERICA, NEVER.
THEY STILL BELIEVED IN THE
SYSTEM AND THEY WORKED WITHIN IT
TO ARRIVE AT THE RULING THAT
HAPPENED TODAY.
NOW THEY LIKE TO PRO-LIFE
REPUBLICANS THEY HELD COUNTLESS
PRAYER VIGILS.
THEY PUSH FOR PRO-LIFE LANGUAGE
IN THE PLATFORM.
THEY HELD DEBATES, THAT A CAMPUS
OUTREACH THEY SET A CRISIS
PREGNANCY CENTERS MANY WHICH ARE
UNDER ATTACK RIGHT NOW.
THEY CONDUCTED SIDEWALK
MINISTRIES THAT WERE RIDICULED
FOR IT.
THEY HOSTED AND ATTENDED THE
MARCH FOR LIFE FOR DECADES.
RAIN, ICE, SNOW, SHINE.
WILL OF COURSE THEY ELECTED
DONALD TRUMP WHO WOULD PUT NOT
ONE, BUT THREE JUSTICES ON THE
COURT TODAY I MUST NOT FORGET HE
WAS THE VERY FIRST SITTING
PRESIDENT JUST BE TO SAVE LIVES
LET ALONE ATTEND THE MARCH FOR
LIFE.
>> UNBORN CHILDREN HAD NEVER HAD
A STRONGER DEFENDER IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
EVERY LIFE BRINGS LOVE INTO THIS
WORLD, EVERY CHILD BRINGS JOY TO
A FAMILY.
EVERY PERSON IS WORTH
PROTECTING.
AND ABOVE ALL WE KNOW THAT EVERY
HUMAN SOUL IS DIVINE IN EVERY
HUMAN LIFE BORN AND UNBORN IS
MADE IN THE HOLY IMAGE OF
ALMIGHTY GOD.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: THIS IS AN IN THE
PROMPTER I'M JUST GONNA SAY
THIS.
IS THE BEST SPEECH I THINK HE'S
EVER GAVE.
HE IS GIVEN A LOT OF SPEECHES,
THAT WAS VERY SPECIAL.
MEANWHILE THE LEFT, THEY LOSE
ONCE THE COURT AND THEY'RE
THREATENING TO TURN ON THE WHOLE
SYSTEM.
THEY WANT TO TAKE DOWN THE
SENATE, THEY WANT TO BLOW UP THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
NO SUPREME COURT ITSELF.
THEY HATE OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
DEMOCRACY.
BUT THIS DECISION LIKE THE GUN
DECISION YESTERDAY SIMPLY
FOLLOWS UNDER THE LINES OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
MEMBER THE SECOND AMENDMENT
CLEARLY PROVIDES FOR THE RIGHT
TO KEEP AND BEAR ARMS IN THE
LEFT LEG KNOW IT DOESN'T.
MEANWHILE THE CONSTITUTION SAYS
NOTHING ABOUT ABORTION BUT THE
LEFT CLAIMS IT IS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS CAN'T BE
MADE OUT OF OLD THOUGHTS IT'S
LUDICROUS.
BUT THAT IS WHAT THE COURTS
STUPIDLY DID IN ROE V. WADE.
DON'T YOU LOVE THAT WEST MARQUIS
TALK ABOUT TWISTED LOGIC OR A
DOCUMENT MUST LIVE AND BE
PROTECTED FOR A LIVING WHILE
PREBORN HUMAN BEING MUST HAVE NO
RIGHT TO LIFE AT ALL.
IT'S VERY LOGICAL.
AS MUCH AS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
BIG BUSINESS AND MEDIA THEY WORK
IN SILENCE AND DEMORALIZE THE
PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT ALL THESE
YEARS IT DIDN'T WORK.
THE PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT WAS NOT
LEFT BEHIND.
IT DIDN'T FADE AWAY, THE NUMBERS
IN GOLD OR DIE OUT INSTEAD OF
CAP RENEWING ITSELF AND IT GREW
STRONGER AND YOUNGER.
A DECADE AFTER DECADE HE
CONTINUED.
OF COURSE WE STILL HAD A PROBLEM
BECAUSE TOO OFTEN REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS KNOW WHO YOU ARE
PROMISE TO APPOINT PRO-LIFE
JUSTICES BUT THEN KEEP THEIR
PROMISES.
THEY ALL VOTED WITH THE JUDICIAL
ACTIVISTS ON THESE RELATED CASES
ON ABORTION.
NOW CONSERVATIVES INCLUDING
YOURS TRULY DO NOT FORCE
GEORGE W. BUSH TO HOLD THE
NOMINATION BACK IN 2005, SHE
WOULD'VE BEEN ANOTHER VOTE TO
UPHOLD ROE V. WADE, THANK
GOODNESS WE HAVE SAM ALITO ON
THE COURT.
WE ALWAYS SEEM TO BE 1-TOUCHE
VOTES SHORT THEY SAW A CHANCE TO
CHANCE OR PARTY IN THE COURT.
SO DONALD TRUMP WAS NOT PART OF
THE G.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT WAS HE?
HE WAS ON THE POLITICIANS WHO
WOULD LET US ON FOR DECADES ALL
LIP SERVICE ONLY TO DISAPPOINT
US AT THE END.
HE PROMISED TO BE DIFFERENT.
HE WAS A THREAT TO THE OLD
GUARD.
HE PROMISED TO APPOINT PRO-LIFE
JUSTICES WOULD HOLD FIRM MATTER
HOW MANY THREATS THEY RECEIVED
FROM THE OUTSIDE.
CAVANAUGH THEY ALL VOTED THE
RIGHT WAY.
MANY REPUBLICANS DOUBTED THOSE
PROMISES BY PRESIDENT TRUMP, BUT
MOST OF US DECIDED TAKE A
CHANCE.
AND IN THE END PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP KEPT HIS PROMISE,
MITCH McCONNELL AND THE
REPUBLICANS OF THE SENATE THEY
KEPT THEIR PROMISES AS WELL.
AND TODAY, FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE 1973 OUR CONSTITUTION IS
FREE OF THE TAINT OF ABORTION.
THIS COURT IN THIS DECISION
SOLIDIFIES PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP IS ONE OF THE
GIANTS OF AMERICAN HISTORY.
FOR MANY AMERICANS THIS IS LIKE
THE BERLIN WALL COMING DOWN.
SUMMING THAT THEY HOPED AND
PRAYED WHAT HAPPENED, BUT IN
THEIR GUT THEY NEVER THOUGHT IT
WOULD REALLY HAPPEN.
ALL OF THOSE WHO CLAIM THAT
DONALD TRUMP WILL BE BAG FOR
CONSERVATISM THEY OWE HIM UP AN
APOLOGY TONIGHT.
IF YOU'RE HONEST WITH YOURSELF
YOU WILL APOLOGIZE.
HE GOT MORE DONE IN FOUR YEARS
IN THE BUSHES DID IN A COMBINED
12.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN WE ALL
WONDER IF IT'S WORTHWHILE TO
SPEND SO MUCH EFFORT AS WE DO IN
POLITICS GETS TIRING, GETS
DEPRESSING, GETS DEMORALIZING.
WE MARCH, WE PRAY, WE DONATE, WE
SPEAK, WE GO ON TV, WE WRITE, WE
ORGANIZE, WE VOTE.
MANY TIMES YOU CAN'T TELL REALLY
IF ARE MAKING MUCH OF A
DIFFERENCE ARE THINGS REALLY
GETTING ANY BETTER?
I DON'T KNOW?
BUT SOME DAYS IT'S DIFFERENT,
SOME DAYS YOU WIN AND SOME DAYS
YOU GET TO CELEBRATE AND GIVE
THANKS THAT YOU WERE ALIVE WHEN
OUR PRAYERS WERE FINALLY
ANSWERED IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA FINALLY DID THE RIGHT